we have a beautiful place in the reason  a lot of swamps a lot of wooded area  beautiful fishing area put it people  really knew it's not the killing field  only law enforcement notes would really  happens out in the fields it's a killing  field of ducks on all of murders because  of the last thing the deterioration of  the evidence that's greater and greater  every day and it makes the case a hell  of a lot harder to solve usually walk  Fontaine she was deducted in 1997 and  now as she laid front three months later  she was found dumped in a raggedy-ass  ditch in their mail pouch detective on  call Brody Sanchez I called the rule of  law enforcement is you never make a  promise specially as a homicide  detective to anyone that you're gonna  solve that case and I broke that room I  got to meet a mother she looked at me  and she said rody please father I went  up to my door  Kida fields meaning